dans la cour des invalides des candidats
à l'élection présidentielle tous bords
confondus sont venus rendre hommage aux
harkis
car je reconnais les responsabilités des
gouvernements français dans l'abandon
des harkis des massacres de ceux restés
en algérie et des conditions d'accueil
inhumaines des familles transférées dans
les camps en france martine tâche de 101
db aidé les bills reste sur le drapeau
tricolore
marianne deuxième étape c'est la mise en
place de mesures d'insertion économique
et professionnelle et puis peut-être
accordé la légion d'honneur à l'ensemble
des harkis qui restent vives en fin de
la cérémonie et des poignées de mains
observé à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
envie vous avez déclaré je suis sûr que
nicolas sarkozy est honnête vous pouvez
leur dire sans rire perdu le président
du modem a bien du mal à se faire
entendre dans le paysage politique et
craint d'être asphyxié par cet homme
emmanuel macron qui pourrait lui
disputer le petit espace du centre en
5min km devrait marche
il ya eu au moins deux des faits
magnétique que macron en 50 mètres
devant une caméra alors comment faire
pour faire parler de ce mouvement il est
meilleur que moins à cran à l'écouter il
a vu chez rothschild et il a fait
l'école et comme je n'ai pas une
approche de fonds de commerce
ou de paysages mort de la vie politique
et puis je sais pas pourquoi toutes les
caméras lui colle au cul moyens que moi
emmanuel macron fait un pas de plus vers
2017 il est soumis qu'elle l'invité du
sommet des réformistes européens
organisés à lyon depuis le lancement des
invitations emmanuel macron a
démissionné de son coin c'était beaucoup
de participants qui se sont désistés
comme pierre moscovici ou encore les
think tank de gauche terra nova
je trouve que c'est toujours dommage
quand elle n'a quand on a quelque chose
à dire de ne pas venir l'échangé il ya
une interprétation qui fait on n'a plus
grand chose à dire les pressions
traduisent une fébrilité donc demandé
aux fébrile nous ne sommes pas j'aime
ferait pas campagne pour valls je ne
ferai pas campagne pour macron je ne
ferai pas campagne pour hommes chez
hollande
ces deux qui se sont comptées lmnp
dégoûter tout le monde qu'ils ont fini
par faire fuir les électeurs parc devons
démanteler complètement définitivement
le campement de la lande parc c'est un
peu pathétique il a toujours un coup de
retard surtout on le voit ne pas être
allé à calais pendant quatre ans et demi
et se préoccuper du sujet à huit mois
des présidentielles quand même un peu de
décence on envie de dire partout sera
fait d'ici la fin de l'année et je
reviendrai avec le gouvernement après le
démantèlement complet et entier de
calais pour qu'il n'y ait pas de doute
sur nos intentions et sur notre volonté
oui je suis un mal à l'aise et un peu
dans une ambiance un peu nauséeux
heureuse de voir en permanence des
sujets très grave
complètement être l'objet de campagnes
électorales le président est en campagne
électorale tout les jours je veux aussi
redire ma détermination à voir les
autorités britanniques prendre leur part
dans l'effort humanitaire que la france
accompli ici et continuera à accomplir
demain plus un échec un échec un échec
grave pourquoi parce que c'est un échec
qui est construit sur le reniement et le
renoncement le reniement sais j'ai d'une
chose je fais le contraire
le renoncement c'est j'ai même pas
essayé françois hollande n'est plus
crédible
en tout cas je crois que les français
quand on les écoute disent des choses
extrêmement dur rien échec il pourrait
commencer par lui-même
je crois qu il était en responsabilité
pendant plus de deux ans au gouvernement
il a exercé des responsabilités très
importante donc cet échec s'il y avait
chez cos en swing le dit elle le
concerne au premier titre face à lui
emmanuel macron salle il a une image
volée un soutien tous contre sarkozy
confond l'économie française est
aujourd'hui dans une situation d'urgence
absolue et le changement de politique
économique
c'est la seule alternative possible
faire en sorte qu'ils vous soutiennent
parce que vous êtes candidat il ne l'est
pas encore s'il vient de me dire je suis
derrière toi méfiez vous quand il était
à laquelle le travail cinquante mille
chômeurs de plus c'est un résultat
décevant inattendu d'ailleurs je dois le
dire nos anticipations défavorable lié
aux difficultés rencontrées au lendemain
des attentats du mois de juillet dans
certains secteurs notamment dans le
tourisme dans l'hôtellerie dans la
restauration et dans le commerce de
loisirs se sont malheureusement confirmé
paris je vous rappelle l'engagement de
françois hollande ces jeunes à leers pas
la courbe du chômage ne serait pas
candidat c'est à lui maintenant de
prendre ses responsabilités parce
qu'aujourd'hui le candidat nicolas
sarkozy ne fait pas du buisson sans lui
sont en essayant d'aller sur les plates
bandes du front national pour
l'affaiblir
si ça c'est pas de la balle gamme qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un mannequin
enfin je pose une question je vous
répond j'ai un cerveau j'ai pas besoin
d'être lobotomisés par qui que ce soit à
la charge contre nicolas sarkozy patrick
buisson l'accusent d'avoir parlé de
valeurs comme nationaliste anti orgueil
en colère et mauvais que son conseiller
premier réalité et deuxièmement je vous
dis le fond du fond du fond de ma pensée
cela n'a aucune importance politique
mais c'est une vraie déception humaine
par ses pulsions qu'il avait dit que la
case idéologique de nicolas sarkozy est
évident
j'en suis convaincu je pense que nicolas
sarkozy ne pense rien que c'est un très
bon candidat qui sent le vent
électorale mais que c'est un très
mauvais président qui ne sert pas les
intérêts de la france et on l'a vu
malheureusement pris aucune
réconciliation possible avec patrick
buisson
ce n'est pas un sujet pour moi
secrétaire clinton
tout va bien eh bien je veux que vous
soyez heureuse c'est très important pour
moi
vous avez soutenu la guerre en irak
avant l'invasion
c'est faux je n'ai pas soutenu la guerre
en et 2002 en fait tu te trompes a
soutenu l'intervention en irak avant
qu'elle ne commence et il a fallu
attendre plus d'un an après pour qu'ils
changent de position
ginanni le look ni l'endurance
absolument pas l'endurance nécessaires
pour être présidente de notre pays comme
mend tamana quand il aura voyagé dans
112 qui négocier un accord un cessez le
feu
la libération des six ans et le vers de
nouvelles opportunités dans le passé on
leur a témoigné devant le congrès il
pourra me parler d'endurance le maire de
locminé grégoire super c'est un des
premiers parrainage que j'ai acquis ça
s'est passé au mois de mai sur un capot
de voiture
la photo a été prise dimanche dernier
audi vous allez bien se trouve à bobigny
en seine-saint-denis et franchement je
trouve assez cool ça françois fillon
j'ai signé le parrainage sur le capot
d'une voiture s'était pas avec nathalie
sous le capot de voile pour les besoins
de l'histoire de laure histoire il
fallait que je sois fachos salon et pour
couronner le tout escroc eh bien je
crois et je suis sûre même que les
français qui liront ce livre auront une
toute autre idée de mort l'ancien
conseiller sulfureux condamné en 2014
pour avoir enregistré nicolas sarkozy à
son insu décrit un ancien président
manipulateur et franchement pas tendre
avec ses collègues
je sais bien que je suis le tom cruise
du pauvre mais enfin gérard larcher
ministre ce n'est pas possible il est
trop laid au fond c'est lamentable c'est
méprisable
je n'irai pas plus loin l'ancien chef de
l'état aurait eu des mots très durs
envers ses collaborateurs
françois fillon un pauvre type christian
estrosi un abruti avec une noisette dans
la tête
françois baroin un second rôle le crédit
que j'accorde à ce personnage
à ces méthodes emprunté à la stasi je
porte quelque chose de vrai dans ce
livre c'est ce qu'ils aient cessées
l'opinion sur estrosi qui l'aurait elle
qui l'aurait pois chiche dans la tête ça
me parait scientifiquement prouvé il
peut dire n'importe quoi n'importe
comment dans n'importe quel bouquin dans
n'importe quelle interview
ce crédit est entre 0 - 1 finit par et
c'était quelqu'un qui a été très
intéressé aussi très très affairistes
dents quand on voit son histoire c'est
quand même pas une victime
un nouvel élément ressurgi dans la
sphère du financement les biens de sa
campagne
oui un carnet de notes qui mentionnerait
une série de versements profit nicolas
sarkozy juste avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 marché celui qui
aura appliqué à la politique
le principe de la pyramide de ponzi a
cumulé les sur promesse en période
électorale avec la ferme intention de
maintenir
aucune une fois au pouvoir paraît
scarlets appartenait à un ancien
dignitaire du régime de mouammar kadhafi
retrouvé mort à vienne en 2012
on ne sait pas que c'est nicolas sarkozy
qui la nouaille est gênant j'irais pas
jusqu'a leur nom mais vous savez
aujourd'hui et plus limites mais plus
limité quelque chose qui se passe c'est
la faute de nicolas sarkozy écoutez
attendant le prochain chez lui au puy en
velay qui lui ont même valu de se faire
chambrer au conseil régional
je vous ai vu à la fête de l'oiseau dans
ce dans ce magnifique petit col ans
l'avait alors qu'alain juppé confirme
son statut de favori à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle et accroît son
avance sur nicolas sarkozy
selon les derniers sondages il est de
moins en moins bordelais
c'est du moins ce que reprochent les
élus de l'opposition municipale au maire
de la ville alain juppé
en dépit de votre tentative de séduction
je ne suis pas preneur
nous sommes tenus de faire un projet
municipal tous les trimestres et je
m'interroge sur le point de savoir si on
doit passer à ce régime j'te ce serait
de bon pour notre santé à tous vous
faire baisser le taux d'adrénaline
voilà quatre fois par an ça c'est assez
facile fréquence concerne en tout cas
pour voir certains d'entre vous avez
raison je suis maniaque facile non plus
mais surtout on s'appelle un jeu
vraiment 06 par l'imprimerie de
dammartin-en-goële où s'étaient
retranchés les terroristes les frères
kwasi rouvre ses portes aujourd'hui plus
d'un an et demi après l'attentât de
charlie hebdo une inauguration en
présence de françois hollande a priori
il est partout et que nous devons lutter
lutter avec la force lorsque c'est
nécessaire je parle de la force armée
lutter aussi avec l'esprit avec des
idées entendez vous autoriser les mères
à disposer de l'identité des personnes
habitant leur commune et inscrites dans
le fichier est sacrée impression que
pour un certain nombre de collègues ce
n'est pas une rentrée c'est une sortie
au regard de ce que sont ces piges et de
la nécessité de préserver la
confidentialité la transmission des
listes de personnes s à ce jour est
juridiquement impossible le coup de
déprime c'est vous
c'est vous qui leur rappelait à tous les
moments qu'ils ont un coup de déprime
quand je les vois ils n'ont pas de coût
des primes ils sont combatifs donc la
seule chose que j'ai à faire c'est de
gérer les journalistes qui leur disque
dur écoute des peignoirs écoutez madame
la sénatrice ne remettait pas en cause
la parole de cette affaire là ou alors
on rentre dans un autre débat
et moi je vous parlais d'alstom
précisément sur chacun des dossiers
alors vous qui l'avez vu travailler il a
été surcoté il est surcoté banal mac os
je crois que quand des partis l'aller
c'est quand même un certain nombre de
dossiers en suspens c'est un lieu de
débat blâme la sénatrice et vous avez un
autre comportement quand je suis à
strasbourg à ce moment là vous avez un
autre comportement vous ne soyez pas
différente à strasbourg ici pour des
raisons de basse politique
paris peut pas voir le discours à paris
un discours à strasbourg devant le
double discours
c'est dur quand même vous titiller un
petit peu j'ai vu qu'il était très
énervé même devant la base c'est ce même
devant l'outrance même devant la
calomnie
même devant la trahison on ne recule pas
qu'ils regardent et là pendant votre
reportage ce sens qu on sent que qu'il
n'est pas en paix qui n'est pas apaisé
qu'il ya quelque chose de 2 voilà du
je sais pas comment vous dire ça je suis
pas psychologue mais je trouve qu'il
n'est pas en paix le 27 octobre
il y aura un gros problème car le maire
de bordeaux favori des sondages a prévu
de longue date un meeting à marseille
il se trouve que nicolas sarkozy compte
en organiser un le même soin et juste à
proximité
la politique la guerre des clans qui est
la guerre des clans qui se poursuit
entre mais je vais refaire la guerre des
clans étant clos marine le pen n'aura
pas fait l'effort de rassembler son
propre camp
elle ne constituera pas pour moi comment
dirais-je est une candidate indiscutable
marque puis si de l'autre côté il ya des
électeurs du front national qui tout
d'un coup chemise dans sur jupe ce parti
nous amène dans le mur bien moi je
n'exclus personne quand on veut
rassembler on ne commence pas par
exclure faudra d'abord nous attraper
faudra d'abord nous aborder au beau
pavillon